heute wie gesagt ich habe es von anfang
an schon
gesprochen
haben schwarzenegger hat gerade auf
instagram eine große tolle rede gehalten
indem er eben aus seiner zeit erzählt
als er den großen andere größten
gewichtheber russlands getroffen hatte
persönlich getroffen hatte und
und hat diese nachricht speziell an die
russen gegeben das
ist also ist eine zehn minuten rede die
ein bisschen gänsehaut macht und
vielleicht schaut man da auch mal rein
was mich immer also auch befangen macht
das und was ich hörte was sehr sehr
traurig ist dass viele der jungen russin
auch die in den krieg ziehen gegen ihr
eigenes bruderland kämpfen müssen erst
ja gar nicht wussten dass sie in einem
krieg sind als special operation genannt
und so weiter und ich habe selbst auch
freunde hier in los angeles die schäme
sich dafür die sind dagegen es gibt also
das muss man ganz klar sagen ein großer
großer teil der in russland diesen krieg
nicht möchte ja das ist also ganz ganz
wichtig auch mal zu sagen auch die
deutschland osten habe ich gelesen
gehört dass die auch schon bei uns
angegriffen wurden mit zweieinhalb
millionen auch da müsste man die leute
zufrieden lassen die die die schämen
sich ja selbst dafür dass russland da
gerade macht und gerade tut und
wir können nur auch immer wieder
hergehen und sagen wir müssen von innen
her versuchen auch dass die russen an
punkten rangehen
versuchen ihn zu stürzen weil sie nicht
ob das geht aber das sollte schon sein
sehr richtig ich würde einmal die frage
zu frauen vor dem paul du bist lifecare
vor ort was herr müller gerade
angesprochen hat mit dem verhältnis dem
bruderkrieg dem verhältnis zwischen
ukraine und russen wie ist das bei dir
welche erfahrungen was wurde dir erzählt
darüber wie schwer fällt es vielleicht
dann auch ukraine in den krieg zu ziehen
empfindet man sich da noch als brüder
das ist eine wirklich sehr traurige
entwicklung wenn ich daran denke wie es
2013 war während des mannes während der
proteste da haben viele
auch der führenden figuren immer darauf
geachtet dass es nicht gegen russland
interpretiert werden sollte sogar man
wollte auch versuchen putin in
anführungszeichen nicht zu sehr zu
provozieren ich erinnere mich da auch
noch an viele gespräche mit vitali
klitschko wo die mutter aus russland
gebürtig kommt der vater aus der ukraine
man war teil der sowjetunion
das spielte nie eine rolle also es gab
nie eine art feindschaft zwischen der
ukraine und russland
aber das hat sich sehr verändert durch
den krieg bereits im osten ich habe
einen guten freund aus donets kommt der
stadt die schon seit 214 dort umzingelt
wird der wollte einmal zurück in seine
stadt fahren da wurde er fast standen
auf der auf der straße erschossen weil
man ihn als verräter ausgemacht hat weil
an der west ukraine war konnte zum glück
entkommen
gleichzeitig gibt es viele verbindungen
zwischen ukrainern und menschen die in
moskau wohnen oder in anderen teilen
russlands und das ist eine total
verrückte welt der manchmal sitzen wir
hier in kiew und mein ukrainischer
kollege mit dem ich arbeite ruft seinen
russischen freund an der am telefon ist
und er sagt dann wie kannst du denn hier
mit den nazis und das sind doch überall
nazis hier und es ist er versuchte zu
erklären dass das nicht stimmt aber
diese propaganda und da will ich dem
widersprechen das wirklich so viele also
das ist zumindest mein gefühl dass
wirklich die große mehrheit putin
ablehnt das kann ich weder in den
meinungsumfragen erkennen noch in dem
was ich persönlich erlebe also mein
gefühl ist dass diese propaganda noch
zumindest sehr sehr stark dort verfängt
ja das braucht alles seine zeit paul
aber ich habe heute gesehen szenen
gesehen aus moskau das ganz normale
leute auf der strasse sich um zucker
geprügelt haben zucker ist jetzt der
der mangel stoff in russland es wird
zucker gehortet aus furcht vor
vor hunger vor allem was was danach
kommen kann das heißt die erkenntnis
dass da irgendwo krieg geführt wird der
negative folgen hat diese erkenntnis ist
inzwischen in russland auch ganz unten
angekommen also ich glaube es gibt nur
noch ganz wenige menschen die glauben
die gar nicht wissen dass da in der
ukraine irgendwas stattfindet das
braucht alles eine gewisse zeit aber
dann kommt es auch an und wie wir an der
zucker frage sehen kommt es im leben der
normalen merkel an die machen keine
keinen aufstand gegen putin das wird
nicht stattfinden sondern die fahrer ist
frage ist wann sich jemand im
machtapparat entschließt putin
abzuservieren
da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht dass es
nicht um die massen geht uli nur mein
gefühl ist dass putin unser gesamter
propaganda apparat ist schaffen kann
auch eine ein mangel an lebensmitteln
oder einen mangel an zucker oder was
auch immer sozusagen im westen
anzulasten wie den schlimmsten oder
eigentlich noch schlimmeren zeiten des
kalten krieges und zu sagen die wollen
russland klein machen so wie es jetzt
schon versucht die von russland kaputt
machen und wir müssen jetzt gemeinsam
hier stehen gegen die bösen mächte im
westen das verfängt leider immer noch
sehr stark aber wie welche probleme
dieser machtapparat hat erkennen wir
auch schon an einem kleinen nebenaspekt
die russische diplomatie im ausland
beispielsweise in berlin der botschafter
hier ist nicht zu sehen was soll denn
auch sagen zu diesem krieg sollte er
sagen die ukraine eingeladen ja
natürlich sagt er ab was soll er denn
sagen die die wahl gleich alle haben ihn
eingeladen wird endet nazi feed der ist
von tausenden eingeladen worden die
ukraine werden entnazifiziert und
entwaffnet soll er diesen ganzen unsinn
erzählen die diplomaten hier schweigen
er das heißt der ganze auslands apparat
des außenministeriums lahmgelegt die
können nur durch praktische arbeit dafür
sorgen dass ein paar dinge noch
funktionieren die sie brauchen aber
argumentieren können sie nicht mehr und
das bleibt nicht ohne rückwirkung auf
moskau da bin ich überzeugt von mir
geben nach zugreifen weil er dessen
these ist ja auch wahr ich hab sie
gerade im hintergrund bedeutet sie
wollten antworten ist immer etwas
schwieriger wenn man digital zu gescheit
ist und sich direkt einmischen kann
wir haben die diskussion wahrgenommen
und auch das paul natürlich gesagt hat
dass er da er eine verfassung sind die
stattfindet
dass die ich hoffe dass das richtig
verstanden habe also die propaganda die
paula auch angesprochen hat
die auch gerade
die ist ich habe hier einen freund und
produzenten der letzten tage sagte er
konnte auch die mutter nicht mal so
erreichen also wie gesagt internet usw
das ist ja auch alles überwiegend
abgestellt und so die haben auch
wirklich schwierigkeiten auch wenn es
wichtige informationen zu bekommen
damit man dass das ganze wenn man sich
das wirklich vorstellt dass im grunde
familien verwandte gegeneinander kämpfen
und dass dieser putin auch noch sagt er
der nazismus gegen die nazis kämpfen
der präsident der ukraine dessen vater
hat
europas
33 sind im konzentrations
camp ums leben gekommen er ist jude und
allein schon diese thesen aufzustellen
dieser die sind diese diese dummen
schwachen thesen an das andere an die
leute zu geben
das zeigt doch dass putin gar kein
interesse hat er führt gespräche gemacht
und lässt doch gleich weiter bomben und
und immer mehr sterben usw nochmals ich
glaube was im moment nicht liefern
waffen liefern ernährung aber was ganz
wichtig ist ist einmal der der flug
himmel also oben das da dass die
natürlich das ist ein ganz ganz großes
problem dass da der russe an fliegen
kann und im luftraum beherrscht und dann
nochmals auch wir müssen den gürtel so
ein bisschen manchmal auch enger
schnallen wir müssen auch schon mal
jetzt war dahinter stehen und es ist
möglich
ich würde auch die akw sachen wieder
also die die warum nicht ich wieder rein
ergeben der franzose baut 15
verschiedene
atomkraftwerke neue und wir schalten die
dinge alle ab ich weiß es hat auch
nachteile aber im moment ist alles das
wichtig
alles das tun mit den amerikanern
verhandeln akw um energien mehr zu
bekommen alles das was wir gegen
einander was gegen dann angesprochen hat
ist aber jetzt wichtig es geht hier um
menschenleben und solange wir
kaufen und den milliarden reinschieben
in den arsch templin wird er weiter
brutal kennen und mördern jeden tag das
muss man sich klar bei eingehen und das
merkte man ein kommt deswegen dass man
da sagen ich muss auch noch einen sagen
ich habe lebt das jetzt ja auch schon
jetzt in seit dem kriegsbeginn paul und
seine kollegen kameraleute grauens leben
auch von amerikanern von fox die vor ort
sind die auch ihr leben riskieren das
ist ein wahnsinn ich hatte damals auch
noch mit vitali gesprochen wenn man das
mal bedenkt wir leben in 22 22 und ich
habe ihn schreiben müssen dass das er
gebraucht wird das erleben muss dass die
leute ihn brauchen auch den präsidenten
da spricht man zu einem freund gibt mir
eine gänsehaut über das dass das jeden
tag sterben kann dass ich glaube dass
das geht so das zeigt ja schon was bei
euch da jetzt im bundestag wieder
gelaufen ist die hören sich das an und
schon gehen die zu anderen themen über
richtig weiß nicht sein gemeint schlimm
wer sie hat ja doch mal in das ist so
schlimm und menschen entwürdigend was da
gelaufen ist da kann man sich nur mit
dem kopf schütteln dass das merkt man
gar nicht reinbekommen ja dass die dann
dazu glückwunsch sache nochmal übergehen
das ist mit einem netz immer wieder
bewusst aber wie gesagt solange wir den
fischern diesen dieses monster finnen so
lange wird dieses monster auch weiter
fressen und töten ganz klar
ein punkt ist ganz entscheidend wie
können wir dafür sorgen dass auch putin
in russland immer kritischer gesehen
wird das ist ja eben auch angeklungen
und je länger der krieg dauert und je
mehr menschen auch in russland das
merken auch wenn das langsamer läuft war
natürlich die propagandamaschine von
putin angeworfen wurde desto größer ist
dann auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
putin in schwierigkeiten kommt und
deswegen müssen wir die ukraine auch mit
waffen weiterhin unterstützen damit die
ukraine sich wehren damit sie sich
verteidigen können denn wenn wir mal
ganz ehrlich sind als der krieg begonnen
hat haben doch die meisten in
deutschland gedacht in zwei drei oder
vier tagen ist putin mit seinen truppen
in die ukraine überall einmarschiert und
die das ukrainische volk hat kaum eine
chance und wir sehen jetzt dass das
ukrainische volk über drei wochen
richtig tapfer und gut gekämpft hat und
dass die gegenhalten und je länger der
krieg dauert desto kritischer wird auch
putin gesehen war natürlich der sein
umfeld das merkt aber auch das russische
volk und da liegt auch meine hoffnung
dass es da langsam eine bewegung in
russland